foreign
I had the coolest moment possibly ever
in stand up speaking of cigarettes at
the cellar that night he got off stage
and he coming he came and hung out at
the table and he was sitting next to me
holding a cigarette and I was like I
always want to know what kind of
cigarettes I've been like I've been
going to see you since I was 16. yeah
just want to know what kind of
cigarettes you smoke and he was like oh
I smoke American Spirits yeah I was like
this is we're at the table at the Olive
Tree yeah inside and I go oh you wanna
go smoke a cigarette
and he goes smoke right here and I go
whoa I can't because I need this place
for rent but you're Dave Chappelle you
can smoke here if you want to and he
goes you can if Dave Chappelle likes
your cigarette
and I looked at SD and SD went like that
and I I took and I swear to God by the
third drag yeah every waiter and
bartender was staring at me like
shoulder gets to smoke inside yeah yeah
and I was like this is unbelievable yeah
yeah I took a couple hits and I put it
in the I put it in like the ashtray and
just he was like thank you yeah but I
was like dude that was I got smoke
inside that's that's the uh ultimate
measure of Fame yeah is that there's
literally places where they go like this
city will find us and shut everything
down and police are going to come and
he's like I'm Dave Chappelle yeah I mean
he just smokes you're just standing in
the hallway and you're like you can do
this and he's like I can and he just
smokes it's amazing it's crazy I bet he
could smoke at a hospital yeah
like probably that baby's about to be
delivered
[Music]
I said so close to your newborn's face
I can't believe you shoved that out of
your [__] lady your [__] is never
gonna be the same he's hitting the baby
with his knee with the umbilical cord
Dave can you need the umbilical cord
yeah you want to leave a legacy where
you're like don't come back and make it
[__] Eddie Murphy should not come back
to stand up comedy there's no Legacy yes
there is no Legacy look let me see
something who's one of the best Comics
that died in the last 10 years Patrice
right yeah none of the kids know him
that's not true that's not true okay
you're naming someone who's well if you
if you have no hours out maybe there's
no Legacy uh oh that's a shot oh no why
did you look at me when why didn't you
look at me when you said it did I tell
you that I noticed that too yeah
you took the shot
and say it yeah take the shot if you're
gonna take the shots take the shot
you're gonna shoot a guy in the back
yeah yeah no you shoot him you know what
he did he sucker punch you yeah yeah
no I was just saying the Legacy thing
you know that you have the good friends
I love how ready he's getting go ahead
yeah go ahead slow down you have to put
something out there to get a legacy I
know what I'm saying though is is that I
know so many great Comics that have died
right sure correct
okay but what he's saying is if you've
built up if you built up something no
one has it in this day and age in 100
years the future people are gonna go oh
look at um Caligula by Anthony Anthony
they're not going to say that someone
might one guy who because they're dead
no but he's not saying yeah Bob's sake
of take the Legacy thing out yeah as if
fans of yours yeah if you come see me
live
but that's the Jay Leno Theory that's
what he said yeah come to me live He's
not gonna put out hours because he says
just come see me live until I don't do
it anymore so what I'm saying is that
what you did what you did
what you did dude yeah nope like 911 I
will never forget never dude okay what
you did was put a plain inside my body
yeah two of them all right you know what
and I'm falling right now dude and what
you did dude I'm never doing your movies
that movie that you want to do
it right now a lot of people a lot of
people say fancy they say that he took
the lessons on how to take off but never
had a land
[Music]
but let's be honest you are very this is
very nine eleven because you do
self-implode this is what are you doing
now dude nothing yeah whoa dude I'm just
saying You lyrics it just looks like
maybe the planes didn't do as much
damage as some of the internal inside
job
I don't know if his comment can melt
steel beams
yeah
[Music]
and if you were around the fancy Bobby
comment please check in because you
might have some carcinogenics
Paul Giamatti walked by my car the other
day oh yeah I see Peter Dinklage a lot
nice really he's a child at the place
[Laughter]
come on
I'm like
anytime you're bombing on stages unzip a
duffel bag okay serious
I'm like Madam because you can't fly I'm
like we're getting chased by the cops
you [__] [__] make this bike fly
what are you good for
I thought you had powers
[Laughter]
but you could also snatch him up
I heard he's kind of it's just small
voice
crash into the East River
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'd be so mad if people were talking
about snatching me up and taking him
yeah yeah yeah I was so mad for some
reason it was it made me a lot less
angry than an American crowd because
when they when they had those [__]
late show the crowd's hammered like
throwing up
puking everywhere
every single show I was there the next
night after someone you were in Where
Were You When someone puked up Fort
Worth Texas no no that was Fort Wayne
you're like
the Theater
Detroit people threw up wow they were
like this is good they're the people
that are on the venue were like it's
really great to have you but they were
there was so many people threw up
[Laughter]
comedy clubs was way worse than the
theaters because theaters I can't see
yeah there's not like a rush of like
waitresses and staff but the old when I
was doing clubs it would be throw up
into your glass that was a consistent
that's a gentleman though that's kind of
interesting it was like is it the rewind
it's a natural thing that people just
instinctively were doing like no one was
communicating this this is just a common
thing where dudes will just throw up
right back into their buying glass it's
instinctive and they did
why are they doing this now
no one even rushes to go to the bathroom
straight over the block of the floor
lady in New Jersey was my favorite
because she threw up and she was the I
was the only one that could see her
throwing up because she was doing it she
was in the front row and she was doing
it very quietly but if she was she was
drinking red wine she was just going
just a fountain of red puke
she's going up right now Fort Wayne a
guy threw up straight onto the floor and
it was so loud
so loud
like morning sickness it's a funny scene
showing up hilarious oh my gosh
[Laughter]
oh I should get up I should go to the
bathroom [__] it
you're in the middle of a [__]
25 minutes into a set and I was just
like this thing's done right everybody
we're done there's a civil war guy in
the front he lit half the crowd looked
like they were from the Civil War like
just beards just pieces of [__] dudes
from Indiana the guy in the front was so
blacked out he just he had his head down
the whole time and occasionally he would
just be like ah
I was like all right man waitress was
doing the fart noise that was that same
show waitress literally while Tommy was
on stage a lady went
real loud I thought somebody actually
farted I mean I was like damn that's
hilarious and it was a waitress walking
by me it was like I did that like
waitress literally a heckled a comedian
oh my God and then she bragged about it
and then she told me then the whole
staff loved it they were like wow and
then I got on stage as soon as I got on
stage I heard the fart noise again I was
like was that the waitress
and they were like the owner's leaving
his wall like yeah
what are you guys doing lady in the back
just kept going show us your tits
don't show us your kids you can't put a
cardboard goddamn thing in the oven but
it will not withstand the high sustained
heat of the oven the only reason I'm
arguing this point is because you guys
started sucking on that link Cuisine
saying it was a pillar of microwave
Cuisine I'm saying fine it is but a Hot
Pocket is too it is the king snack of
the microwave name me another only
microwavable snack that could compete I
don't think there is another
microwavable snack that anybody enjoys
yeah that's what I'm saying there is
nothing nobody enjoys a microwavable
somebody's enjoying it baby 40 Years
baby can you name even something
semi-close to uh to a Hot Pocket no
one's even attempting to make them drosa
because they suck nobody dude that's a
that's a dying thing that's like an AM
radio station nobody breakfast
sandwiches microwave only awesome
awesome awesome
yes what are we saying Jimmy Dean
microwave breakfast
you gotta cook them in a microwave
cowboy
okay yeah speaking of Italians have you
ever met uh Chef Boyardee the famous
I know what my parents did I use cereal
yeah talk to me guy I had a whole list
of questions but whoa Here We Go Again
New York is a place where you just bump
into people yeah so all the news anchors
and stuff are just they're going down
34th Street I find those are the hardest
people to bump into though the anchors
because no matter how hard you bump into
them they just won't budge
that's their you know their anchors
that's why they're called anchors they
don't move I know but that's why I'm
saying guy they're they're tough to bump
into yeah nonetheless chefs are there
famous chefs and your parents have met
Boyardee oh many many times talk to me
guy like sit and talk it's just New York
New York you just there's there's Chef
Boyardee and there's you know Kermit or
whoever and you just wait
the we talking them up yeah it's do
yours is it it's not like when you're in
the city it's not a special like oh my
God Chef Boyardee so good to meet you
yeah it's just like you're on the street
I'm on the street where I have a train
to catch good to see you you know so
they were really friendly with them and
they I think they went to see music
together
Broadway uh Radio City Music Hall so
that go see what they go see Liberace of
course yeah did you wear the hat does he
always wear the hat you know did they
say anything no okay that's like a work
hat right right right but you almost
want them to when you're out because
it's like that famous Hattie War you you
want them to but it's he doesn't want to
yeah because he was actually really good
with his fans that's the thing that was
crazy like you know my parents are like
hey well you know Shield you from all
these people running out and then people
be like hey I love your food and Chef
Boyardee was like would stop
talk to them what's your name yeah
what's your name what's your name what
are both of your names yeah what are
your last names
where do you live
um what do you do and he really took his
time with people because his whole thing
was yeah I'm a chef but I learned
everything I know from everybody else
isn't it indicative of a chef to want
the details what's your last name who
are you what yeah yeah because to them I
feel like with Boyardee and and I I
didn't meet them you did so my parents
did your parents didn't stop me if I'm
going to before before my time but I
feel like everything he picks up on
these details are ingredients Fred you
know yeah and he mixes them all together
and it's almost like the people the
streets New York becomes a recipe for
that that cat yeah
yeah it's
which is why he was so big you know I
don't get to the top Rd yeah you know
they named uh Lucas named R2D2 after I
didn't know yeah that was the esophilum
or whatever when you can a Kylie Lim oh
what's it called when you squish a word
R2D2 is a derivative of Chef Boyardee
R2D2 is it was he one of the robots he
was the robot the [__] one yeah that
only knew how to whistle and Chirp like
a bird that had just smashed into a
window I brought Bagels but I only
bought cinnamon raisin in plain and Sal
like came in and he's like what the [__]
who doesn't buy everything bagel and I
go why the [__] would I've done that and
he goes it's the best bagel it's gonna
go no it's not cinnamon raisin is and we
started [__] screaming at each other
it's egg but go ahead
it's egg or cheese but go ahead egg
[Laughter]
one that's always empty no it's not
Bob's the one that's always full egg or
she had a bagel and put an egg on it nah
dude egg bagel
egg the yellow egg bagel or the cheese
bagel or something something I've said
it before and I say it again you lost
weight and you you used to be beautiful
I don't know what the [__] you're
talking about anymore with food egg
you have said [__] to me in the last
year about food since you lost weight
where I'm just like he's lost his Edge
this is like when Miles Davis stopped
doing heroin and the music sucked you've
lost your [__] Edge what are you
talking about I lost it I lost my fat
Edge yes uh
what all this problem is out of control
in this city I'll tell you that right
now
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're gonna get this guy a job
it's just too hot out man sun's out guns
out it is cloudy though so I have no
excuse three degrees Yeah it's hot stock
what's going on bikes up here it's humid
do you get it do you fish with a stick
is there a bag on the end of that stick
are you riding the fridge
she's looking friends you do like like
the second guy in command behind Moses
in the desert right now I'm here if you
need me Moses the only time you actually
like perfectly hear about new music is
usually when it's like a pop star now
you know it's like Taylor Swift is
releasing something you know like you
don't have to be a fan but you'll hear
that yeah it just it permeates yeah it's
like and that has to be like because
someone's gonna do like just
the chair sorry the chair sorry it was
the chair scared she scared the [__] out
of me I was in the chair that's better
go ahead okay
well guys I thought I was dying yeah
that's scared that scared that [__]
happens I'm glad you were saying okay
yeah how true do you think his shirt is
stand up Bobby
is that a true statement No gaping holes
here
um
do I think it's a true statement I would
say it's a pseudo truth so I would think
that I would say that it's a pseudo
truth that it it it it is true
it's the Baseline truth I think at
moments of the day for sure you're
gaping I don't think that you're always
gaping so I want to say that it's true
now but through the lifetime of you
wearing that shirt today I think at some
point today you will be gaping because I
don't think that with the experiences
you've had in your life and the things
that you've done in your history you
can't not gape a little bit each day
[Laughter]
progression it's almost like an
accordion like you know it's a pressure
system it depends on the barometric
pressure if you're going to higher
elevation if you're taking a flight
there's no way you don't gape but if
we're at sea level you know you just
told me you just woke up I don't know
that you're necessarily fully gaping
right now but you will gape at some
point so no gaping holes here might be
true right now at this moment by the end
of this podcast
all day every day
with that he's in uh she's in the head
of the Gay Pride Parade
I'm keeping home oh yeah
I'm a gay pure right okay yeah I gave
him John wave Casey
right that's right very good guy you're
very good and quick thank you I
appreciate it but um don't do that here
have you ever had any chocolate before
yeah oh yeah my first girlfriend
chocolate really yeah she was doing my
first girlfriend the the very first time
we had sex I mean I lost my virginity to
this girl she'd already had sex the very
first time I had sex we were in my
mother's house my mother wasn't home we
were dating for like two months she was
this beautiful black girl half black
half Jamaican half Italian
she was a basketball player right up my
alley and so Victor wimbing Yama yes
that was her name yeah and she yeah she
looked like um she did no she looked
like well let me tell you what she
looked like Sam Cassell Sam Morrell
Sam Burrell and so she looked like Sam
Cassell and and Vito put a picture of
Sam Cassell up in that she looked like
Sam Cassell with hair
he's such a weird looking I know
who he is no [__] idea
she's like I don't see color I'm 24. but
I wish I had taken more advantage and
been more honest even with the guys that
I came up with to say I kind of feel
like I'm losing myself a little bit and
then by the time I got to the Pinnacle
my mom and dad are sick I'm fighting
cancer with them but I'm also the
biggest comedian in the world and so
every day I step off stage and I go
right home to like try to you know I'm
talking I'm dealing with hospice as the
crowd is [__] still rifling out of
Arena number 180 I was just with Al
Dudley my old tour manager 181 Arenas
over two year period a Arena's beer
shitty series like Arenas that like
shouldn't have even been we did Hassan
Hussein's Arena over in Iraq legit like
we're you name a spot in the world we
went there did you bomb but uh no I
[__]
I killed no bomb uh Bobby altoff yes
yeah so we had her on BFFs you started
drama with uh yes so we we
um we asked her did she like did she
sleep with Drake Drake yeah and she
answered no this is a Texas so we had
her on the show The Drake stuff broke
after but since I knew her I texted her
I'm like hey I'm hearing you slept with
Drake and you got divorced is that true
kind of joking like it's just is she's
like off the Record
um no not true and something else we
retold this story on BFFs next week in
our editors edit it and made it appear
kind of seem like she was about to
confirm something salacious yeah and it
went Uber viral yeah I went ballistic on
my social team I don't want questions
I don't know no I don't because you know
what that clip was gonna do but I didn't
do it but even before no even before it
became a big story when she says off the
Record if you talk about this off the
record conversation that you know no it
isn't Because the actual here it is
because the actual clip it was all
together so when we were filming she she
said off the Record haha no it's not
true I said here's a response ha ha off
the Record it's not true I said it all
together they cut me like the clip cut
his point would be and I'm a fan but I
have to say this his point would be if
she says off the Record
it's off the Record no I disagree
if she says
no it's not true yeah a misogynist would
say that if she says she would
definitely say something like that she
says you machine it no it's off the
Record and she says uh off the Record no
it's not true together those two don't
mean anything if she said off the Record
yeah I slept with them
she's being sarcastic yes off the Record
no it's not true correct like off the
Record yeah it's true don't mention it
you don't have to have something off the
Record if it'll never happen right
exactly she wants that lie to be out or
that rumor to be out there because it's
no she clearly didn't it because no no
because she didn't address them no no
she yeah you got the same difference she
what I'll say is she would like people
to think it might have happened she
definitely did she went crazy
but I understand I understand like the
sarcasm here it's like if uh if I'm like
off the Record never had sex with Paris
Hilton you're like you don't need to
tell me that correct it was like she
didn't say [__] it was like dude like
did you sleep with Drake and your uh
marriage is ruined it's like off the
Record no like okay one more time push
back I'm gonna dunk on you but go
I went to a foot doctor she she goes
your feet and then she kind of had no no
words like that and then she goes you
have no fat on the bottom of your feed
she goes no wonder you're in pain you
have no fat and then you have a bone
spur on the heel you have a arch
collapse and you have arthritis and a
hammer toe and I I just don't know how
you can walk but through the power of
Christ
a little prayer so anyway I found a new
way to walk okay
I'm back here okay centered here it's
very awkward but I go that looks normal
dude
it looks like you're walking not down a
hill
do they play The Pink Panther music as
you're walking
I can't I can't believe you're striking
out on the apps big guys
[Laughter]
you never thought that was weird either
I thought the Pink Panther crystallized
what I'm doing hey where you ladies
going slow down I got a hammer toe and a
taser it looks like you're walking the
wrong way on a moving sidewalk
stuck on an escalator
I'm glad my chronic pain is a source of
laughter
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out